[Music]
street food a cupboard market in corona
virus
it doesn't sound like a recipe for
success
we've come to south london's brixton
village to see how the restaurants here
are coping
small independents run tight margins at
the best of times
so how do they respond when the pandemic
hit
and how can they survive the post lock
down future
[Music]
tim we've done the michelin star
restaurant we've seen the local
neighborhood restaurant
we're here at brixton village market
today quite a different scale to the
places we've been so far what's it going
to be like for these guys
it must be really challenging it's going
to be pretty awful for them
i mean this isn't just a matter of
getting balance
small independent operations are
absolutely the sort of the majority the
backbone of this
this sector and the other thing that
most civilians don't get to be honest
is how tight their margins are i mean
everybody in the restaurant industry
yeah your margins are tight that's fine
that's great when you've got a
six million pound operation in west end
these guys margins are
really talking pennies but it'll be
interesting to see now whether
those people who are stuck at home
working from home for the foreseeable
future whether they're gonna
come to the rescue for a lot of these
small independent guys and as we're
proving with everything we've done so
far it's about the relationship
to the local community all right let's
go and see
the markets general manager diana shows
us around
the restaurants here rub shoulder to
shoulder with grossers butchers
fishmongers and retailers i've never met
a female fisherman
and they were all given a three-month
rent break during lockdown
we're also interested to hear that this
place is grade two listed
meaning it has to be preserved not for
its architectural beauty
but for its cultural diversity our
responsibility as a custodian for the
market
is to ensure that the retail mix is
retained so there must always be
a latin american butcher there must
always be a caribbean
fishmonger there must always be esme who
sells
natural and organic natural and organic
herbs
that she ships over from the caribbean
so it's those sorts of tenants that have
that have to be preserved
so this is written into your listing
it's bizarre
sorry i say bizarre it's actually so
beautiful i've never seen listings so
splendid and bizarre so what if i'm a
mcdonald's what
can i come can i no thank you you know
this space
really cultivates individuality and just
independent entrepreneurship
they get it wrong a lot of the time but
through that comes experiences and just
really really great
yeah great great tenant mixes
brian definitely has the entrepreneurial
spirit he says he was panicking when the
country locked down in the restaurant
closed
but he's not only survived he's thrived
the rent break furnace scheme and that
reduction were a big help but he was
ready to do anything
for instance this is what i would plan i
bought a lawn mower
just in case i couldn't work any food
i'll walk anymore to go and cut grass
you've got your face on the sauce bottle
damn it you know all this going on and
yet still in the back of your mind there
was a point in there when you were
thinking
i might have to go more people's horses
i have to do anything anything that's
necessary to
to to be relevant to make money for my
family to feed my family
to pay my mortgage and everything like
that you know what i mean
instead of mowing lawns he's used social
media to stay in touch with the local
community
ramped up takeaway and streamlined his
menu to save costs
two things brexit and as well as the
covet the prices for some
some items have gone up so of course we
had to
take that out of the uh take that
component out
and focus on just getting them the money
not just right just
to be on pace to be focused you know i
mean and that was the idea and that
worked
fantastic for us i changed the price the
prices a bit
the rum punch for instance we were doing
a big and a small one we're doing just
the big ones now anytime you have
situations like this something always
comes out of it
and you have to really be positive and
get it done
that's how you look at it as an
opportunity there's always opportunity
like this you
take this into as a as a learning curve
improve yourself they have the resources
and they have the agility
to actually do that yeah agility is
important but
you have to be agile in this in this
business if you can't maneuver and if
you're just stagnant
you get you get beaten so this is how
you know we were able to kind of move
tables around
and you know change the structure of the
restaurant we can if we had to change
this restaurant to take away tonight we
can do it boom
easily if agility is one word that comes
up a lot
community is another moto runs ocam
she's been serving up down to earth
japanese food for years
[Music]
when covert hit she didn't know what to
do
what happens when covid hits oh gosh
yeah completely stopped and just
thinking
what should i do when should i reopen
should i do contin and open the
take away or not or i need to save my
staff
safe keep safe so i shouldn't open
take away even and so just going around
round but there's no answer
when the restaurant did reopen it was
the community that gave her the
encouragement to keep going
from the local people saying how are you
and are you open
well done and this kind of repeating
repeating hearing the
kind of word and warmth just feeling
i thought okay i think okay wouldn't
gonna burst
you're optimistic as optimistic as you
can be
yeah i think that's that's always my
character
that kovi 19 made me
definitely very weak and nervous is it
fence that you feel supported by the
community
yeah not necessarily they come to buy
from us
some people will buy from us get this
from us
but some people i've seen them maybe
over
last five six years almost once a week
or once a month or
recognize we don't know names each other
but we recognize faces
you're saying like community as it
affects your mental health yeah
it makes you it makes you strong that's
tremendous that's at that level
yeah that is so exciting to find that
but what i love about restaurants is the
soul
and the emotion and the feeling of being
loved true hospitality
and that's and what what you're saying
is is that that's being rewarded
those are the ones who are going to
survive this
footfall in the market has plummeted as
much as 90 during lockdown
but it started to return to more normal
levels
diana says that one positive from the
pandemic is how bridgeton's old and new
residents
have been brought together in the same
space at the same time i've always seen
this market having
an old brixton and a new brixton that
visit it
the old brixton has you know has lived
here for decades and slowly started to
move out of brixton perhaps living in
croydon living in pearly
because they perhaps may not be able to
afford it but they still come here to
get their produce and their goods they
come in the morning they use it as their
community space and they enjoy it
then they go home at six o'clock new
brixton leaves brookston at eight a.m
they go into victoria they go in talks
with circus they go to pond street and
work
and then come back at 6 p.m so when old
brixton leaves new brixton comes and
then enjoys our nighttime economy
what we learnt was actually when new
brixton wasn't allowed to go to work and
had to work at home
they were then spending their time
shopping and using
the space like old brixton so there's
now yeah henry and katie walk around the
market
where previously it was patrice and
ronald's honestly and i yeah and i
really love that and they walk side by
side now
thank you
well first thing i'm going to say tim is
not only am i impressed that you've got
your
face mask with you you've also got your
own chopsticks this is commitments to
the
covered security course no it's it's um
it's just easier i mean you know i think
more people should carry their own kit
the one thing i would say having spoken
to a few of the
food vendors in this place is how
kind of heartwarming it is that most of
them are telling a really positive story
i mean
they're obviously at the sharp end of
this thing but most of them seem
actually quite optimistic so these guys
do have a positive outlook
because their landlord has looked at
them and said okay we've got to keep
these people here we've got to help them
out they've given them this three-month
break if they give them a break they
give them the double continue to
continue to get the rent breaks they're
already um
predisposed to help small and diverse
businesses
in the first place and here this is kind
of the definition
of what london community should really
be about it's
massively diverse it's warm it's
friendly it's diverse by class it's
diverse by
by culture by ethnicity and so on and
and it's and it works
well look if these noodles are anything
to to go by i hope that i hope the
community does stick with it
and we get to enjoy another bowl
sometime soon absolutely
[Music]
um